hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of day two of the super United
rapid tournament currently being played
in Croatia it is a Magnus Carlsen versus
vishwanathan Ananda and I even have
their head-to-head score in Rapid chess
for those of you who are interested so
Magnus defeated Vichy 23 times so we
should defeated Magnus 12 times and 29
Times They drew their games so Magnus in
the lead here but who is in the lead in
the tournament is definitely Vichy if
you remember uh We've checked out uh uh
uh the the games yesterday uh which is
leading the tournament and uh he has a
great day too he started by defeating
evancharich and he dragons Fabiano
caruana and Magnus got two losses in his
first two games of day three of day two
and now uh well they they uh they they
both really want to win if Anand wins he
pretty much is Unstoppable in this
tournament he would have to lose like
two two in a row which is not impossible
Magnus lost two in a row uh but uh you
know he would be very very close to
winning the tournament and if Magnus
wins he is definitely back in the race
so now let's see what happened here
Magnus as the white pieces and he opened
with E4 we have C6 Island goes for the
Karo Khan defense with D4 D5 and now not
the main Knight the C3 or even the
advanced variation with E5 Magnus goes
for the exchange variation uh with e
captures on D5 unant captures and now
again not even the pawn of attack Bishop
to D3 instead we have Knight to C6 by on
and C3 defending the pawn here and just
Pawn to E6 with Bishop to F4 by Magnus
and now Bishop to D6 offering a trade of
dark Square Bishops and Magnus goes for
it captures captures and Knight to F3
Knight gt7 and both players just Castle
so nothing spectacular here from White
you do have some nice
and pressure here on the on the king
side but nothing uh nothing really
happening there so we have Rook D1 and
now Pawn to F6 by on and there are some
other games that reach this position
Knight the G6 is a normal so G6 is a
non-move but upon the F6 has never been
played before and it is now as of move
10 that we have a completely new game
and not only that pawn to F6 is the top
move or rather one of the top moves
recommended by the engine so on and of
course knows very much how to treat this
position you take away the G5 Square
from the Knight so you don't have to
worry about any tricks like Bush page 7
Queen to H5 and also later on you will
have support for executing any uh
central breakthroughs with maybe Pawn to
E5 so okay we have C4 by Magnus now as
the king's position has been weakened he
of course wants to open up this diagonal
I don't just trace the characters Bishop
captures and now Knight the F5 and now
of course they're both the bishop and
the queen are uh sorry uh defending
these six Pawn we have Pawn to D5
captures captures with check and just
King shade nothing really happening here
Knight to C3
uh and the bishop to D7 and I'm just
continuous development with Queen to B3
Now sort of putting pressure on the B7
pawn and uh Anand goes back Queen to C7
not just to defend the pawn but also you
know that Rook is coming to D1 so you
don't want your queen on D6 and that's
exactly what Magnus plays rookie to D1
Rook 8 d8 the counter Magnus is broken
D1 and now Pawn to H3 creating a little
bit of a breathing room for the white
king uh Bishop to C8 opening up the D5
for his rook and also adding more uh
defense to that B7 pawn and queen to A3
by Magnus putting pressure on this
diagonal but also with some ideas of uh
sorry about the weird Arrow of Knight
the B5 putting pressure on the queen and
the A7 Pawn so Knight F the E7 attacking
the bishop and just Knights the B5
attacking the queen we have Queen to B6
and here Magnus goes for it Knight
captures an A7 there are other moves you
could consider here like maybe Knight
coming the D6 is a move also you could
play Bishop address and C6 but Magnus
plays Knight captures on A7 and it's not
easy to deal with this there are uh well
there are definitely easy ways to go
wrong here yeah for example if the
Knight moves then the Knight and E7 is
defended but it's that much better if
the queen characters if Queen captures
you will still capture Force the Knight
away and then of course go for Rook
captures on E7 and always uh White
should be a little bit better as white
is up a pawn but Anand says all right
you will be up a pawn but it's gonna be
a doubled B Pawn so it's not going to be
as impressive he goes for Knight
captures on D5 Knight captures on C8
with Rook captures on C8 and now Rook
captures on D5 Rook to A8 you have to
play this so now uh the queen has to
move and you have to also defend the A2
Pawn so you have to play Queen to B3 and
here Anand very happily trades captures
captures and goes Rook to F7 okay Magnus
is up a pawn but it's a double B Pawn
and I believe Anand would be very happy
with a draw here to Simply extend his
lead in the tournament uh we have Rook
D4 by Magnus King to G8 and now Pawn to
B4 preparing Pawn to B5 we have Rook the
d8 offering a rook trade and the Magnus
obliges with Rook captures Knight
captures and King to F1 now Magnus wants
to get his King up the board and the
island of course does the same King to
f8 but for the moment the king cannot
cross the E file King D2 Rook the C7 now
we have King to D3 King to F7 and now
Knight the D4 uh here uh there are a
couple of moves on and could consider
like you could consider advancing those
King side pawns you could go maybe Rook
C1 trying to go behind the pawns Anan
decides to go uh for Knight to the C6
attacks the pawn and the Knight on D4
and the Magnus trade with Knight
captures and now Rook captures on C6 so
now you will uh probably attack those
pawns and hopefully Magnus will not be
able to do anything about that Rook to
C4 uh of course Anand cannot trade as
Magnus is up a pawn doesn't matter if
it's a double Pawn if it's a king and
pawning with no pieces then it will be
winning uh Rook to D6 check Rook to D4
Rook back to B6 and now Rook to D7 with
check with King G6 of course Anna needs
to take care of the G7 pawn and the King
to C4 we have rooked the C6 with check
and now King to B3 with uh Pawn to B6
now getting the pawn out of Harm's Way
and now Rook to D2 and defending the
back rank with rooked the E6 uh and now
just King the A4 trying to get over to
the to the B6 pawn and then maybe some
Rook to C2 then Rook to C6 then you win
the pawn then maybe you make some uh
advancements so Rook D5 of course
stopping the king from advancing and now
Pawn to F4 we have rocked the E4 and now
Rook the F2 defending the F4 Pawn we
have Pawn to H5 and now Pawn to F5 with
check King to G5 and now King to B5 so
how can Anand stop the the B6 Pawn from
being lost well at the moment he cannot
with Pawn to H4 King characters on B6
and now Rook captures some B4 with check
that's why the Rook is on F2 now the uh
the V2 Pawn is nicely defended King to
C5 and now Rook the B3 so now Magnus is
up a pawn but it is no longer a double B
Pawn now it's just a clean beep on his
upper Pawn uh we have King to C4 now
comes Rook to B8 and now of course the
strongest moving chess ever played Ponta
B4 uh Rook to see it with check with
King to D5 uh Rook to B8 attacking the
pawn but just King to C5 Rook to see it
with check of course we all know what
these are these are spite checks we have
King to D6 and now Rook to B8 attacking
the pawn not just the Rook the B2 with k
in captors on F5 but now Magnus played
Pawn to B5 and it was in this position
on move 53 that's the vishwanathan
island resigned to the game and uh uh
well uh well deserve the victory for
Magnus Carlsen in the final round of the
second day of the super United rap
tournament in Croatia so he starts with
two losses but then he finally gets a
win against the leader of the tournament
vishwanathan Anand who's been having
pretty much a perfect tournament and now
Magnus kind of ruined it but still I
believe that uh Anand will remain in the
lead but other games are still being
played so we'll have to see what happens
now here okay it might seem like a bit
of a premature resignation but it's not
uh to give you an example okay let's say
you start pushing those King side pawns
you don't really have anything else
let's say b6g for let's say captures
captures King to C7 you attack The Rook
Rook the eight trade now trying to mix
things up well you could maybe Advance
the pawn Rook to B3 is the safest way to
go let's say Rook H7 check King to D6
now the B7 and now you just repeat and
kick the Rook away King C6 rugby 18 to
C7 the road goes back or or somewhere or
even after Rook to B8 you go B7 first
you don't even have to attack The Rook
now that's pretty much it F5 King to C7
you have to sacrifice The Rook for the
pass Pawn otherwise it's gonna become a
queen and yes you do get you do have two
pawns and the white king is far away but
there is just no way for the king or the
pawns to cross the F3 and H3 squares as
they are defended twice by both uh the
Jeep on and The Rock so there is no move
here the king cannot get across the
pawns um I cannot get across there is
absolutely nothing here so of course
after B5 it's uh it's uh you know a good
resignation definitely not premature and
the Magnus uh takes the win the first
win of the day so uh other games like I
said are still being played we're gonna
uh discuss if you have any favorites use
hashtag suggestion and I will gladly
cover it and then we are going to
discuss the standings after day two of
the Superbad United a rapid tournament
and here you can see just how sad Magnus
was after losing the second game tool it
is like he was the first game to five he
was a really really quick defeat and he
lost the second game while it is I look
at him here uh he cannot believe it uh
how how does one lose two games in a row
it's absolutely crushing for him but now
he gets uh you know at least a little
bit something back so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed a tough luck
for vision but still three more rounds
Anything Can Happen uh the the uh you
know they they have to fight I would
like to thank James Eugene Cashman and
Josh or John Austin uh not complace uh
bullet just thriller.com and Paul Miller
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful tournament
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day